[موسيقى]
القهوة هي مصدر جيد لمضادات الأكسدة
التي يمكن أن تساعد في منع أو تأخير
تلف خلايا معينة في الجسم ، وتقول دراسة هارفارد
إن بعض المركبات الموجودة في القهوة
قد تحمي أيضًا من الالتهابات
التي يمكن أن تدعم صحة دماغك عن طريق
تقليل تلف الخلايا العصبية الناجم عن
الالتهاب وخطر الإصابة
بحالات التنكس العصبي مثل
مرض الزهايمر أو
التصلب المتعدد ينخفض
ًا عن طريق تق
يل الالتهاب.  يُظهر أن خطر الإصابة بالاضطراب
في وقت لاحق من الحياة
يدعم فائدة أخرى لتخمير القهوة لدعم أبحاث صحة القلب
التي تشير إلى أن شرب القهوة
باعتدال يرتبط بانخفاض خطر
الإصابة بأمراض القلب والأوعية الدموية ، ولكن إذا
قمت بتزيين قهوتك بالكثير من
الكريمة والسكر  يمكن أن ينفي
فوائده الصحية